what do you say to people that say it's
it's just you guys just don't pick the
right women
um that's that's why this problem like
well we're gonna push marriage because
it's you guys you're just not picking
the right women well listen I I this
affects everybody right [__] a few
people I said you know and oh you you
know and you end up every everywhere I
[__] go
I'm getting accosted by people so I
don't buy this as some kind of little
minority issue and if you think it's not
going to happen to you I promise you the
chances are statistically it will
sooner or later it will happen to you
there's a very very high probability
given all the other stats it could
happen